okay in this video i'm going to decode
another question from iit jam 2015 bl
so in this question
they have asked
for a amino acid sequence what they have
given is our top view of alpha helix of
adenylate kinase protein and now they
ask the sequence of
amino acid in which sequence the amino
acids are arranged so once you would see
this question you would think oh my god
this is a hard question and require a
huge knowledge in geometry
no it's really easy let's break it down
for you okay let's go step by step so we
know uh what let's see what they have
asked so this is alpha helix
so basically uh they gave us a top view
so they are viewing from this portion so
we are seeing a full circle instead of a
helix instead of a spiral we are seeing
a circle so what happened so when we uh
but we know that the
in
alpha helix
each residues are 3.6 amps strong
apart so the there are 3.6
i mean sorry i mean sorry there are
3.6 residues per turn i'm sorry so there
are six 3.6 residues
per turn
now
here the full angle is actually 360
degree
here the full angle is 360 degree it is
not given but you know this full angle
is 360 degree
now
if we just divide
it 3.6
it would give
100
so that means
to get another amino acid near to
the amino acid is from valine should be
100
so we have to go 100
and here given that each of these small
sections are actually 10 degrees
and they have also told us that this
valine one is the
start point so you can see in the
options everywhere the start is the
value
so first we would proceed and we would
count our steps so first second third
fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth ninth
and tenth
so we have taken ten steps
so 110 degree into 10 that means 100
degree
so now we are
into the second residue i mean aspartate
yeah
now we would take again 10 turns
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10.
so our sequence would build up like
valine one
then we have aspartate
then again we have aspartate okay let's
try to find the similarity here you can
see in the first option there is valine
aspartate aspartate
okay let's uh so we are here up to this
aspect
let's go further let's again count ten
steps one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten it's valid see
it's valid okay let's again count ten
steps one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten it's phenylalanine so if
we go in this manner we would find that
this option given here
is the correct protein sequence
so see
the questions they ask you in iit is
very fundamental
but they would look like it's terrible
it's very hard but they are very
fundamental and very easy so don't get
confused i hope you enjoyed this video
please like and subscribe for more video
updates